here again are the latest phone calls  between Vladimir Putin and President  Trump  hey bird do we have anything to worry  about  go get this I'm gonna plant a wire on  him that way if he says anything  Adelaide will hear it India's economy  will be broadcast on all major networks  and CNN is dreaming online oh okay then  Plan B it is what is Plan B I'm gonna  let that it put me in a headlock the  order should kill me at about six  seconds hey Brad  Thank You Vlad I got what do you want  nothing  let me guess you're nervous about leaks  and testimonies to your killing time  calling friends oh that true it all  gotta go back Vladdy how can I stop  James Kirby from testifying  leave it to me I send pretty lady to  seduce him taking criminais ting photos  blackmail him then he will do whatever I  want  wait that's what you did to Paige yes No  [Applause]  you